messenger of peace
my objective
and my agenda
is strictly linked to save lives and to
reduce suffering
i had a very frank discussion with the
foreign minister sergey lavrov
and it is clear that there are two
different positions on what is happening
in ukraine
according to the russian federation what
is taking place is a special military
operation with the objectives that were
announced
according to the u.n in line with
resolutions passed by the general
assembly
russia's invasion of ukraine is a
violation of its territorial integrity
and against the charter of united
nations
but it is my deep conviction
that the sooner
we end this war the better
for the people of ukraine
for the people of the russian federation
and those far beyond
the united nations has repeatedly called
for ceasefires to protect civilians and
to facilitate the political dialogue to
reach a solution
so far that has not been possible
today across the donbass a violent
battle is underway with tremendous
deaths and destruction
many civilians are being killed and
hundreds of thousands of people are in
life threatening conditions trapped by
the conflict
i'm concerned about the repeated reports
the violations of international
humanitarian and human rights law and
possible war crimes
and they require
independent
investigation
for effective accountability
and we urgently need
humanitarian corridors that are truly
safe and effective
and
that are respected by all
to evacuate civilians and deliver much
needed assistance
to that end
i have proposed the establishment of a
humanitarian contact group
bringing together the russian federation
ukraine and the united nations
to look for opportunities for the
opening of safe corridors with local
cessation of hostilities
and to guarantee that they are actually
effective simultaneously
we recognize that we face a crisis
within a crisis in mario paul
thousands of civilians are in dire need
of life-saving humanitarian assistance
and many of evacuation
the united nations is ready to fully
mobilize its human and logistical
resources to help save lives in mario
paul
my proposal is for a coordinated work of
the united nations the international
committee of the red cross
and ukraine and russian federation
forces
to enable the safe evacuation of those
civilians who want to live
both inside the azov style plan and in
the city
in any direction they choose
and to deliver the humanitarian aid
required
and this is not just about
what is happening in ukraine as we are
seeing shock waves around the world
the dramatic acceleration of the
increase of the prices for food and
energy
that was already taking place in the
last year
are causing enormous suffering to
hundreds of millions of the most
vulnerable people worldwide
and this caps on top of the shock of the
continued cavite 19 pandemic
and the uneven access to resources for
recovery
that particularly penalize developing
countries around the world
and so the sooner
peace is established
the better
for the sake of ukraine
russia and for the world
and it's very important even in these
moments
of
difficulty
to keep alive the values of
multilateralism
we
need a world that is multi-polar
with multilateral institutions
and those multilateral institutions must
abide
by the end charter and by international
law
and abiding by the event charter and by
international law recognizing full
equality among states
they hopefully will be an instrument
that will allow us once again to come
together as humankind and address the
dramatic challenges we face
from climate change to epidemics and to
many others
and in which
the only war
we should have
would be a war
of those that put the planet at risk